fermeté ou démagogie nicolas sarkozy a
donc été vivement pris à partie à
l'assemblée nationale après le drame de
la courneuve la gauche reproche au
ministre de l'intérieur une dérive
populiste à ses propos sur le nettoyage
de la cité ont entraîné une passe
d'armes plus qu'animé dans l'hémicycle
alexandre kara bernard connor décembre
de police de la courneuve
l'opposition a répondu aujourd'hui par
un débat musclé depuis trois ans
monsieur le ministre l'état ce que vous
avez passées au kärcher c'est la police
de proximité avec moins 50 policiers à
la courneuve
monsieur le ministre d'état ce que
veulent les gens de la courneuve
ce ne sont pas deux cents policiers et
autant de caméras un jour c'est l'ordre
social et la république toujours pour la
gauche
nicolas sarkozy fait du populisme pour
lui c'est l'opposition qui a perdu le
contact
en voyant la réaction à la gauche de
l'hémicycle
je comprends pourquoi le peuple vous
acquittez pourquoi le peuple s'est
détourné de vous parce que vous avez
oublié sur wayne vous ne parlez pas
comme lui vous ne comprenez pas et vous
ne tirez aucune des conséquences de ce
qu'il vit au quotidien
j'emploie des mots pour être compris le
ministre de l'intérieur répond
les députés ps ont eux dénoncent trois
ans d'inaction et joignent le geste à la
parole
au delà du vocabulaire
certains vont plus loin et met en cause
la personnalité même de nicolas sarkozy
on peut enlever le mauvais lierre avec
le karcher mais il peut aussi dans les
mains d'un individu
contrôlable on arrache le ciment et je
crois que cette image est tout à fait
significative les méthodes brutales à
veules et dangereuse tout conte fait que
monsieur sarkozy
on va pas s'gêner mais non de
l'intérieur a promis de revenir la
courneuve dès la semaine prochaine cette
fois pour parler prévention est sûre